[Musique]
bonsoir les petits enfants vous devenez
ne l'éteint children
nous ne sommes pas encore en angleterre
ne nous que ces patrons alnot mais je
m'exerce ont les cheveux je vais vite
dire bonne nuit à mes deux petits amis
avant de partir ne traîne pas trop
nounours al come back tout de suite
good in children les enfants nous
partons allons en week end à séoul indre
en anglais heures de colle à celle
valable est un non-être est prêt nous
faisons juste un aller retour
nous passons le channel visitons le old
england et nous revenons juste eh oui
comme chic alors vous venez tre very
good et qui nous rapportera des capteurs
plein c'est promis planty promesses
bah si tu nous rapporte des cadeaux non
en fait avait quelque chose pour qu'un
voyage ce qu'ils sont gentils ce petit y
pense tous
tiennent non ses copains je pense bien
des sandwichs au pâté n'ont en jamais
une bouteille de limonade main d'état
fait un chien des bonbons chocolats aux
miennes o'neill
c'est encore meilleur une du fromage au
mans c'est marrant l'anglais et
petits-enfants anglais quand ils veulent
du fromager 10 10
if you please chinois
qu'est ce que tu leur diras je le
redirai nittis à illéla togo d'alu ton
band ou dit bah oui ça change pas quoi
toujours la même chose dans tous les
pays mais petit every you were on y va
[Musique]
buttner le journal comment dit nounours
en anglais nous l'ours nounours ça ne
change pas là j'éteins la lumière du
voyage north un bientôt de voilà bien
chargé nounours patron j'ai du café
chaud des sandwiches ou des bonbons
gueule du fromage
que de bonnes choses nous allons faire
un voyage très agréable merci nico n'a
merci pas pr neil allons nounours les
vents sont favorables en août 2 pas trop
à bientôt
bonne nuit um
[Musique]
oh